and what is the test right what is the
idea a test is to show that you people
are ridiculous I'm giving a Roberto refa
Nettie a hard time here because he's the
editor of the journal sexuality and
culture he agreed to talk to me after
his journal was hoaxed by these people
they submitted absurd papers to 20
academic journals one paper included
gibberish about rape culture in dog
parks another was a section of mine comp
rewritten with feminist buzzwords
editors of seven journals published them
proving say the hoaxers that making
absurd and horrible ideas sufficiently
politically fashionable can get them
validated at the highest levels of
academic reven studies six of the
journal editors wouldn't talk to me
but refa nutty did let's look into it
things and see if we should continue
doing what we're doing maybe you
shouldn't be doing what you're doing
because it's gibberish and they've
proved it yeah yeah they didn't prove
that's the problem they send the
articles to 20 different journals
without asking them if you could study
them which is a basic requirement in
research these days but if they'd ask
the journals they couldn't have done the
test but you're deceiving people without
much of a reason I think the hoaxers had
good reason their hoax woke us up to the
fact that some academic journals publish
nonsense the paper Raffy Nettie's
Journal accepted titled going in for the
backdoor claimed you could reduce
straight male homo hysteria and
transphobia through receptive
penetrative sex toy use correct sounds
like oh it's not a our everyday article
and it's not this is a specialized
journal the deals the sexuality and
culture will decrease transphobia and
increase feminist values mm-hmm yeah
what is the problem with that I don't
see a problem and it is again it's a
statement that could be could be correct
it's nothing really absurd or unusual
but then why publish it oh okay yeah
that's that's an issue
the kitchen that's the specialization
we've been doing that for maybe a
hundred years seems silly yeah okay so
what is silly is the respiration
mechanism in an ant not silly the way an
ant breathes yeah
the way it the way I breathe but that's
facts it's neither breathes this way or
that way this is speculation is it a
speculation if you're just the statement
this thesis not tested we wouldn't do
anything with it
journals say they determine the quality
of research they published by submitting
it to expert reviewers reviewer one this
paper is rich and exciting I'm just
overwhelmed which is a sign of a
marvelous paper he's an idiot they made
up data that he wish or he or she wished
he had but he didn't so when he says wow
these people did this study that I
wanted to do and they got the results
that I thought should be there this is
great the fields were concerned about
put social grievances ahead of objective
truth so as a simple summary we call the
problem grievance studies because
grievance studies journals are so filled
with jargon phrases like these even
nonsense like that dog rape paper can
pass muster
if papers were written in plain English
people might see that some of these
ideas are false or meaningless inferring
from lessons relevant to human and dog
interactions to suggest practical
applications that disrupt masculinities
yes what that's one thing they like
these days to disrupt my schooling this
I don't like that concept it gets your
published that gets you promoted in only
in those departments that support that
well psychology your department leans
that way right in some some departments
in some areas doesn't this show Germans
have a problem is there as such a bias
here the instead of knowledge we just
put in political correctness in some
areas that is the case but again that's
my feeling and I wouldn't do anything
until I can actually you know document
it is a hoax helping the comment that no
it doesn't
it kind of does it I wouldn't have
realized how silly some of these
journals are without this I think
something sounds silly
you watch look carefully and you'll see
it's not as soon as you thought it was
the hoaxers say that in fields that end
in the words studies a culture has
developed in which only certain
conclusions are allowed like those that
make whiteness and masculinity
problematic in some places that is
correct
is that a problem how big of a problem
is it is it worse than hunger right is
it is it worse than you know people
shooting each other why do we need your
drill very good my sexuality and yes yes
you know let's question our assumptions
because maybe we're making an assumption
that we shouldn't be making when
homosexuality was considered mental
illness people pushed in this and the
psychiatrist got together and said it's
a perfectly fine thing to choose and not
to call it mental illness so that's the
type of thing that you know a journal
Exorcist or sexuality in kurtal does is
discuss discussion is good but in most
journals today only some discussions
allowed some feminists assert the dildo
is an oppressive tool of the patriarchy
it just sounds like Polly jargon yes
well but in itself it's just a sentence
right is just describing saying some
women think that using the dildo
is a man idea but that's a correct
statement but it suggests a bias Oh
politically correct correct there is
some jargon that is used I don't like
much and in certain areas you just
learned to live with it in your field
the jargon just goes one way men are the
problem yes and actually I do have a
problem with that you publish it it
doesn't mean I agree with with what they
what they found out shouldn't there be a
little more diversity in your field is
that's what a general thing that we hear
in university campuses right that most
people are on the left a National
Association of scholars report found
that
liberal arts colleges Democrats
outnumber Republicans tend to one I
think it's very reasonable because what
happens what is the job of learning is
questioning assumptions they are not
traditional so not being traditional not
being conservative it's part of the job
of learning doing more open to new ideas
which is you know what being a you know
libro is but this is your left-leaning
definition its conservatives that
propose changes like school vouchers
privatizing air-traffic control all
kinds of new programs while liberals
want more the same oh that's an
interesting point then the hypothesis is
shut down good see see that's how things
that's how things work you show it idea
you discuss that this that the idea and
get it
any right-leaning articles is rejected
no no and and I think that's the major
user point to a couple in your journal
there are rights leaning well I wouldn't
say right leaning because we don't like
either the you know extreme laughter
extreme rights he has published papers
that challenge feminist orthodoxy like
this one saying the me to movement may
go too far there's a push for the the
women's side these days which very
understandably in a reaction because
they for many for a long time there was
a push on the on demand side and a
researcher who had another opinion
wouldn't get hired or published correct
if you don't match what most people
believe you can see they're wrong but
isn't that how you know how humans
handle
knowledge no say the hoaxers to learn
all sides should be heard if they wanted
to make that point that there are people
who are in the extreme left yes there
are people in the extreme left but a
hoax in a publication in the journal is
not gonna solve that problem it's like
you know robbing a bank because you have
to feed your children it's fine but it's
it's you know it's not fine the bank
gets robbed they update their security
systems what have you done I don't think
at this point we have a real
good solution I don't think they do I'm
grateful that Rafi neti was willing to
have a conversation but I cheer the
hoaxers for revealing that much of what
passes for scholarship at colleges today
his bunk